what's up guys in the house production
unit of the nikon zfc
with the nikkor 28 millimeter f 2.8 sc
lens and the nikor dx 16-50 lens but
this lens is gonna be the star of the
show folks i mean it's beautiful it
looks badass on the zfc retro uh night
core design to it um and actually i'm
already noticing some differences from
this production unit versus the
pre-production knit that we did our
first impressions on case in point this
lens feels a little bit more robust a
little bit better made than what we uh
sampled originally also the body on this
camera i mean this is the nikon fm2 come
to life in a digital way it's robust it
feels good as a nice weight to it the
dials the buttons everything feels
really good it's gonna take me a couple
days to get used to how to set up this
camera because i'm used to the nikon z72
and z62 but i can't wait to try it out
anyway full review coming up on the
channel soon so look out for that anyway
take care guys stay safe and i'll chat
to you soon